What do you have for us so far
in terms of the damages
being awarded by this jury to E.
Jean Carroll?
Because of Donald Trump's
defamation against her?
I mean, Jake, this is a significant win
for Jean Carroll.
The jury awarding her
just shy of $100 million in this verdict.
I'm going to break it down for you.
They said that E.
Jean Carroll was injured as a result
of Trump's defamatory statements.
And for emotional harm,
they're awarding her $7.3
million for reputational repair.
They're wording her $11 million
and for punitive damages.
That is the part that punishes
Donald Trump.
They are awarding $65 million.
So my rough math there gets us over
$80 million that the jury is awarding E.
Jean Carroll.
I mean, that is a significant win
from her.
Last year,
the jury awarded her $5 million.
This is just exponentially more.
You know, this is something that is the
jury is sending a message to Donald Trump.
You know, the argument that Carroll's team
has made, which this jury seems
to have completely agreed with,
is that the only way to stop Donald Trump
from repeating his defamatory statements
is to hit him in the pocketbook.
And that is what they've done.
I mean, a significant victory for E.
Jean Carroll,
substantially more than she had asked for.
You know,
she was seeking millions of dollars
and now they're returning this verdict of
over $80 million Jake.
Yeah, $83.3 million. Your math checks out.
Kara Scannell, we'll come back to you
when you have more to tell us.
Let's bring in CNN legal
analyst and former federal prosecutor
Elliott Williams.
All right.
So let's just get your reaction
to these numbers.
Let me let me remind folks what they are.
The compensatory damages,
all told, is $18.3 million.
That checks out to be $7.3
million for emotional harm.
The court the jury found that
he did, in fact, injure her
and $11 million
for reputational harm done to her.
And then so that's 18.3 million,
which is is less than Carroll's
attorney asked for.
She announced for 24 million
punitive damages, $65 million.
Explain, first of all,
what 60 what punitive damages means
and whether or not that's a
that's a high figure for this trial.
Well, it's sort of the last question.
It is a high figure.
That's a lot of money for anybody,
including Donald Trump.
Now, when we talk about compensatory
damages, you're paying someone back
for something they've lost.
And to your point
about the fact that this was less than E.
Jean Carroll's folks had asked for.
It's hard to put a dollar amount
on someone's suffering.
But but she did.
And they said, we think it's $24 million.
They said here that it was $7.3 million.
Now, this question of punitive damages,
how do you deter
someone or others like him
from engaging in the same conduct?
And you put a dollar amount on it
and slap him with a big amount of money.
The challenge here with someone
who's a billionaire or at least 100
million and multiply whatever he is,
whatever, and there he is, he's very rich.
It's hard to put a dollar amount
on his conduct if that would actually
deter him or anyone else.
So they had to put a high dollar amount
on $83.3 million.
That is a lot.
Not as much as Rudy Giuliani was ordered
to pay those two election workers
that he defamed,
but still quite a chunk of change.
Do you think that there is grounds
for an appeal?
Will Donald Trump be able to say
and his lawyers like this is too high,
I didn't get a fair trial, etc.?
There are certainly grounds for an appeal.
Everyone who makes it through
the legal system is entitled
to challenge a verdict or a dollar amount
that's put against them.
The problem is it's substantiated.
She they laid out during the trial
what her injuries were,
whether they were emotional, reputational
or whatever
else,
And punitive damages are hard to quantify.
But it makes sense for an individual
who's who's a billionaire or again,
like I said, or whatever he is,
he gets a lot of money, $83.3
million if you're just joining us.
This was a second defamation trial.
The first one you might remember.
You might remember a jury found that
Donald Trump did sexually abuse writer E.
Jean Carroll.
And at Bergdorf
Goodman's dressing room in the 1990s.
They did find that previously
and ordered him to pay
$5 million
for for defaming her post-presidency.
This trial was about his defaming of her
while he was president in 2019.
And the jury has just awarded E.
Jean Carroll $83.3 million.
So Donald Trump is now
pending an appeal ordered to pay
her, I guess, $88.3 million.
If you add the $5 million
that I assume he hasn't paid her yet.
Let's bring in CNN anchor Kaitlan Collins.
Kaitlan, before this trial,
I am one of the lucky few that actually
has truth social Donald Trump
social media website that he founded back
before Elon Musk took over Twitter.
And if you just scroll through his feed,
it is just
you know,
it's a direct tap into his brain, his end,
and it's just post after post after post
attacking E.
Jean Carroll,
attacking the judge, attacking the case.
This is before the verdict.
So how is he going to react now,
Jake?
I'm told by a person familiar that Trump
just boarded his plane here in New York.
He had actually left the courtroom
before this verdict came down.
He is not in the it was not in the room.
His attorneys were, but he was
not in the room as this is being read.
And I would tell you,
I would not want to be on that plane
with him right now as he is finding out
that this jury has decided he owes E.
Jean Carroll, in addition to the 5 million
that you already mentioned, another $83
million in damages
here, Jake, because, you know, one
sore point for him throughout this
entire trial that you could see play out
in something that the judge
was pushing back against a lot
was the fact that he didn't show up
to the initial trial, which he says he did
on the advice of a previous attorney,
one who's no longer on his team anymore,
I should note.
And that was something
they kept trying to bring up here.
And the judge was saying,
we're not deciding here
if you if you sexually abused her.
That is something
that a jury already found you liable for.
This is just about how much you owe.
And obviously, there were questions
of whether or not the tactics
that they were using inside the courtroom
were going to reduce what he would owe
and what he would have to pay in the end.
The argument that E.
Jean Carroll's attorney was making
was that this is a really wealthy person
in that way to kind of send
a message to him is to choose
really high damages, which, of course,
the jury has delivered on here.
But, Jake, after covering Trump
for as long as I have
what I think of when I look at that $83
million number is this is a man
who does have a lot of money.
He does not like to part ways
with that money,
and he doesn't do so very easily.
So the idea that E.
Jean Carroll,
something that has gotten under his skin
ever since he was in office
until his post-presidency
throughout these many trials
that he is going to over $83
million is not going to go over
well with him.
And how do you think that's going
to manifest itself, Kaitlan?
What is what is next?
I mean, obviously, we're going to see
a lot of truth social posts.
I imagine that that's an easy one
to predict.
Is he?
I mean, he's running for president.
Is he is he speaking anytime soon?
Is he does he have any planned interviews
with any of the the friendly outlets
he tends to talk to?
When are we going next,
going to hear from him on that?
Well, he has a campaign event.
I mean, he's supposed to fly
to Nevada tonight.
I believe he is still on the campaign
trail
as we've seen him bouncing the courtroom
in the campaign trail.
I mean, in court today,
he was still trying to speak up.
He was mouthing words
as his attorneys were speaking,
talking about his denials here.
The crux of this, though, Jake, is
these are four comments he made in 2019.
That's what these damages are coming from,
obviously, as they played E.
Jean Carroll's attorneys played in
the courtroom as this trial was going on.
The moment from the CNN town hall
just back in May, where they were arguing
that he defamed her again,
where he continued to lash out
and speak out against her.
And so I think the question
and the argument that Carroll's attorney
was making during
this was make sure the damages are high
enough to to essentially stop him
from what he's been doing.
Does this 83 million number
mean that to him?
I don't know.
I mean, it's
I think it's hard for people to imagine
he'll stop talking about this
and stop with the denials.
But $83
million is a really high price tag.
It is indeed.
And her attorneys asked for
an unusually high punitive damage award.
And I think it's fair to say
they got it from the jury.